die Mission Jupiter startet wir stehen
auf dem Gelände des europäischen
weltraumbahnhofs
pische weltraum-mission
[Musik]
eine Ariane 5 Rakete hebt ab mit Raum
sind juice an Bord
wir haben hier mit vielen hunderten
Kollegen den Staat verfolgt und ich muss
sagen auch nach mehreren Staats die ich
beobachtet habe bin ich immer noch sehr
emotional und beeindruckt
[Musik]
die Rakete ist inzwischen viele 100 km
über uns in diese Richtung gestartet und
wickelt sich auf die interplanetare
Reise in Richtung Jupiter
gute Reise tschüss
Explorer ist in der Spitze der Ariane
eingebaut von der Rakete sprengen schon
nach zwei Minuten die feststoffpuste ab
dann fallen auch die schützenden Hüllen
und die Hauptstufe ins Meer
schließlich fliegt allein weiter ins All
das erste Signal ein Lebenszeichen von
juice große Freude Erleichterung im
Kontrollraum von Kuru alles hat
fantastisch geklappt nach über 20 Jahren
Arbeit am Projekt juice
nun können auch die riesigen
Solarpaneele ausgeklappt werden
Energiespeicher für die lange
achtjährige Reise zum Jupiter
der Gas Gigant in unserem Sonnensystem
und seine eismonde sind ziel der Mission
ihre Geheimnisse beschäftigen
Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftlerinnen
des Instituts für Planetenforschung
Berlin seit langem sie sind Teil der
Isar weltraumission
juice wird die erste Mission sein
geleitet von Europa die ins tiefe
Sonnensystem vordringt bis zum Jupiter
das ist schon mal eine sehr große
Leistung und die Kamera speziell wird in
der Lage sein die Oberflächen der Monde
in einer Auflösung zu kartieren wie wir
die bisher noch nicht hatten das
Kamerasystem trägt den Namen Janus Teile
der Hardware wurden im DLR-Institut für
Planetenforschung in Berlin entwickelt
Ingenieurin Nicole Schmitz hat bereits
vor 15 Jahren mit den ersten Studien
begonnen arbeitet hier in Berlin am
Boden Referenzmodell der originalkamera
die einzigartige teleskopkamera hat eine
sehr lichtstarke Optik ist eine Mischung
aus Spiegeln und Linsen und muss schon
während der reisephase viele Gefahren
überstehen die Herausforderung dass es
mikromethoriten geben kann die zum
Beispiel in die Optik einschlagen können
das heißt wir haben hier eine
verschließbare Klappe vor der Optik die
die Optik schützt wenn wir im
jupitersystem angekommen sind haben wir
die Herausforderung dass es eine sehr
hohe Strahlungsbelastung im
jupitersystem gibt dafür haben wir
elektronikeinheiten die speziell durch
dickes Material abgeschirmt sind das
Hauptziel der Mission ist ja der Mond
ganimed und die Kamera wird sich bewegen
in einer Höhe zwischen 500 und 200 km
und dafür haben wir dieses Teleskop was
ähm mit einer sehr hohen Auflösung die
Oberfläche kartieren kann
minus 170 Grad herrschen an der
Oberfläche aber im Inneren der eismonde
werden riesige Wasser Ozeane vermutet
die vielleicht Leben ermöglichen
Wärmequellen im Innern durch
radioaktiven Zerfall aber auch
Gezeitenkräfte die Jupiter ausübt
könnten Eismassen verflüssigen
wir denken das ist ein Zusammenhang
steht mit der mit der Reibung die im
Inneren des Mondes entsteht und die dann
Wärme entstehen lässt die das Eis
schmelzen lässt und dadurch könnten
diese Wasser Ozeane entstanden sein die
wir unter der Eiskruste haben
verschiedene Minerale Salze könnten sich
abgelagert haben entlang dieser Risse im
Eis dadurch dass Wasser hinausgepresst
wird unter hohem Druck an die Oberfläche
und dort gefriert das Wasser natürlich
sofort und hinterlässt auch diese
Minerale dann dort an den Stellen
wir haben etwas gebaut womit man eine
unerforschte Welt nämlich die eismone
des Jupiters erforschen kann und dadurch
neue Erkenntnisse gewinnt die uns
Erklärungen zu der Entwicklung des
Sonnensystems geben das zweite
wissenschaftliche instrument ist in
Berliner dacht und mitentwickelt wurde
ist ein Höhenmesser mit dem Namen Gani
mit leser-altimeter kurz Skala es soll
die Information der Eiskruste und das
sind Gestalt messen
galer sendet kurze Laserpulse zur
Oberfläche der eismonde aus empfängt
diese wieder in dem Gerät dieses
passiert 30 Mal in der Sekunde über ein
langzeitraum so dass wir hunderte
Millionen von Einzel Messungen machen
damit können wir eine Topographie das
heißt eine Landkarte der eismonde des
Jupiters erstellen
auch das Heben und Senken der Kruste
wird so analysiert wertvolle Daten über
die Monde und ihre Kilometer dicke
Eisschicht
in der Raumsonde sind die beiden
wissenschaftlichen Instrumente
nebeneinander eingebaut die
hochauflösende Kamera Janus und das
höhenmessgerät GALA erst ihr
Zusammenspiel bringt den Mehrwert der
Missionen
ganz nah am Äquator in Südamerika haben
die Europäer ihren Weltraumbahnhof
gebaut zwei der Berliner
Planetenforscher sind kurz vor dem Start
noch mal verletzte Checks an den
Startplatz der Ariane 5 geflogen
man ist zwar nur ein Rädchen aber man
ist Teil eines großen tollen
internationalen Teams der größte Wunsch
ist natürlich das alles funktioniert
alles klappt das natürlich unser
Instrument funktioniert alles an diesem
startag wenn die Raumsonde auf der
Rakete bereit zum Start ist dann sieht
man dass sich die internationale
Anstrengung vieler Leute gelohnt hat und
wir stehen an einer neuen
Ärger der Erforschung unseres
Sonnensystems
[Musik]
ist das Arbeitstier der europäischen
Raumfahrt sie hat in den letzten
Jahrzehnten bewiesen dass sie einen
zuverlässiger Träger ist und gerade für
interplanetare Missionen wie die unsere
ist eben ihre Präzision extrem wichtig
und wir sind froh dass wir jetzt hier
stehen können ein toller Moment für die
beiden Berliner dies ist die original
Rakete die ihre wissenschaftlichen
Instrumente mit der Raumsonde Richtung
Jupiter schickt
eigentlich großartig weil man hat was
geschaffen man hat was gebaut man hat
eine Hand gehabt und das wird jetzt so
weit weggeschickt zu einem anderen
Planeten so groß mit vielen Monaten und
wird eine wichtige Aufgabe erfüllen man
hat mit viel Herzblut im gesamten Team
diese Instrumente entwickelt und dann
werden sie mit der Rakete den Weltraum
geschossen sechs bis acht Mal im Jahr
hebt hier eine Ariane Rakete ab der
Weltraumbahnhof Kuru wurde in den 80er
Jahren in Südamerika gebaut seitdem ist
er Europas eigener Zugang vom Dschungel
ins All
Karibik Flair in der Stadt Kuru am
Atlantik die dem weltraumstaat Platz in
Französisch Guyana den Namen gab die
Raumfahrt ist hier überall präsent und
wohl auch für die Zukunft wichtig
ein kleines Stück Europa in Südamerika
eine gute Mischung aus karibischer
Gelassenheit und offenbar gut bezahlten
Arbeitsplätzen durch Tourismus und durch
Wissenschaft das Tor zum all 22 Nationen
sind an den Ariane Raketen beteiligt 1,6
Milliarden Euro kostet das juice-projekt
die beiden Berliner haben noch eine
besondere Mission vor sich sie sind auf
dem Weg zum Check ihrer Instrumente wir
sehen das Instrument das letzte Mal
bevor es die Erde verlässt das ist
faszinierend und spannend und sehr
verantwortungsvoll
in einem Reinraum ist die Raumsonde
juice aufgebaut die Berliner treffen
hier auf andere Kollegen aus Europa die
alle letzte funktionsschecks durchführen
bevor du's durchs All bis ins Jupiter
Universum fliegt was ist die Seite die
später auf die Oberfläche der Monde
zeigen wird und darum ist die Kamera und
das Leser halt die Meter auch auf dieser
Seite installiert so werden die
Instrumente Ihre Daten sammeln Daten die
uns Erkenntnisse über den Aufbau der
Mode geben sollen doch wie erreichen Sie
die Erde der Satellit kommuniziert mit
der Erde hauptsächlich über diese große
high gain-antenne wie wir sie nennen sie
Funk zur Erde die Bodenstation auf der
Erde haben Durchmesser bis zu 70 Meter
um eben das schwache Signal aus der
großen Entfernung
empfangen zu können akribisch sind die
letzten Checks an den wissenschaftlichen
Geräten da wird noch mal gründlich
gereinigt und hingeschaut wir müssen
gucken ob keine Partikel drin sind damit
wäre das Instrument blind kleine Risse
können größer werden durch die rauen
Bedingungen wir haben große
Temperaturunterschiede kalt sehr kalt
sehr warm
gereinigt wird mit einer Art Staubsauger
aber auch unter UV-Licht alle Arbeiten
hoch konzentriert
das ist der Höhepunkt der ganzen Arbeit
der letzten 15 Jahre man sieht dieses
Instrument kurz vor seinem Staat das ist
das Beste was es gibt den weltraumtyp
hat die Sonde schon in vakuum-tests in
Toulouse bekommen eine Mitarbeiterin von
Airbus erklärt warum die Solarpaneele so
riesig sind
schon sehr weit weg von der Sonne das
heißt dort ist gar nicht so viel Energie
die wir gewinnen können über
Solarpaneele deswegen hat das westkraft
sehr sehr sehr große Solarpaneele die
man hier natürlich nur eingeklappt sieht
und im Laufe der letzten dreieinhalb
Jahre haben wir natürlich auch die
Paneele getestet und was ein Teil des
Testens war war das Öffnen der Paneele
am spacecraft 85 Quadratmeter groß sind
sie der im Vergleich zur Erde im
jupiter-universum nur noch 4% der
Sonnenenergie ankommt eine
Herausforderung für die größte
europäische weltraumission Leben unter
dem Eis das können wir mit der jetzigen
Mission noch nicht feststellen aber wir
können herausfinden ob es Bedingungen
gibt die so ein Leben ermöglichen würde
ich bin natürlich besonders gespannt auf
das erste Bild was unsere Kamera uns
liefern wird wir hoffen jetzt erstmal
auf einen erfolgreichen Staat und dann
das erste Bild was unser Instrument
zurücksenden wird wird ein ganz
erhebener Moment sein für uns alle
die Entdeckung einer ganz neuen Welt wie
es Bilder anderer Missionen vom Jupiter
zeigen
geheimnisvoll und überirdisch schön